let's take you to afghanistan now where
al jazeera has obtained exclusive access
to the billions of dollars worth of
military hardware left by the u.s and
coalition forces there much of the
equipment was destroyed but now the
taliban says it's recruited
aviation experts to build its own air
force osama bin javid has more from
kabul's military airfield
the kabul airstrip is home to a variety
of afghan militaries hardware from
american blackhawks to russian
helicopters are all lined up here and
many of them are inoperable
where did they cut it yeah they cut it
from here is like this
by hammer that all
glasses
broken and we
can
resolve that all our aircraft because
about
two or three mi 17 is
resolved and they
restarted in the ground in flight also
like this helicopter we also we
completed that outlands but uh
some
lands may be missing to that just not
started
we will try to maybe in two days we will
solve this
row after row scattered all over this
airfield is destroyed helicopters
there's even holes in the fuselage uh in
the bodies the ones that are intact if
you come inside them
and you enter the cockpit
there's nothing here but shattered glass
and destroyed equipment
although many of these technicians have
not been paid for months
they've returned to fix what they can
they found some essential items in
storage and the rest was salvaged from
other aircraft they continue to turn up
for work regardless of who's in the
government
taliban fighters say they've inherited
hangars full of helicopters which have
been destroyed beyond repair but what
they have been able to do is recruit
engineers aviation experts pilots and
convert those fuselages beyond repair
and use the parts to convert helicopters
like these
a taliban commander in charge of 10
airfields told al jazeera at least 20
aircraft including helicopters and fixed
wing cessna's have been rebuilt
most pilots trained by us forces have
left
but some have stayed
and they found dozens of others trained
before the us invasion in 2001.
this is what is left of the kabul
airfield and you can see military
hardware which belongs to the americans
to the russians to the indians and what
taliban fighters want to do is refurbish
all of these helicopters to build their
own air force